begin with a very simple basic
fundamental question
think can you name one good thing
joe biden has done as president just one
in your mind can you think what is he
accomplished that you think is good for
you you we the american people now he
repealed all of trump's border policies
that were working the southern border is
now as we've been chronicling a disaster
we have another investigative report
tonight he promised to eradicate kova 19
and now it has made a massive comeback
and he's responsible for what is the
biggest virus super spreader event uh
not in modern history in american
history and americans will die as a
result of these policies as a direct
result
now he spent your money at a record pace
literally robbing our future generations
now we have inflation through the roof
he halted the key keystone xl pipelines
and other pipelines now u.s gas prices
have never been higher and as a
consequence everything you purchase is
going to cost more to ship and that
means we're all going to pay more for
everything we all buy
he gifted putin with a new pipeline
himself and germany by the way they made
a multi-billion dollar deal with
vladimir he was rewarded with a series
of what after cyber attacks against this
country
compliments of russian hackers this is
what great foreign policy make putin and
make russia rich again well after all
they do have hunter compromised we'll
get into that later too he bribed the
muellers of iran forcing south korea to
turn over seven billion dollars what do
we get as a result they're enriching
uranium now at an accelerated pace he
bowed down to the communists in china
now they're threatening to blow up our
military naval bases lecturing our
secretary of state on human rights and
they let him get away with that and he's
now allowing china to talk about
reunification with taiwan less than a
year after causing a worldwide pandemic
without a doubt joe biden's weak
spineless america last policies are
putting all of us at risk at home and
abroad and it gets worse
in afghanistan well total american
humiliation instead of following through
with president trump's gradual drawdown
of u.s forces biden demanded that we
evacuate entirely by august the 31st
bygone biden told us that a taliban
takeover was not inevitable
he's wrong watch is the taliban takeover
of afghanistan now inevitable no
it is not why
because you have the afghan troops have
300 000
well-equipped as well as equipped as any
army in the world
and an air force
against something like 75 000 taliban
it is not inevitable there's going to be
no circumstance where you see people
being lifted off the roof of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan
and per usual joe biden was dead wrong
over the past month the taliban while
they made tremendous gains all across
the country seizing province after
province after province and they in the
process were able to collect a stockpile
of u.s weaponry and military equipment
left behind by joe during this haphazard
drawdown and now taliban they now
control 60 percent of the country joe
and experts predict that cabo could fall
in less than a month the situation there
is so dire biden is now needing to send
in 3 000 troops just to evacuate
remaining americans in kabul
now in what is eerily reminiscent of
saigon 1975 americans and our allies
will now be hastily airlifted out of
afghanistan just as the taliban is
surrounding the capital biden is now
actually begging the taliban this is a
radical terrorist organization he's
begging them to spare our u.s embassy
and our diplomats inside
begging the taliban
does it get any more humiliating to this
country than that this is the same
taliban that harbored and assisted yeah
osama bin laden and al qaeda prior to 9
11 2001. the same taliban that has been
killing american soldiers for 20 years
joe
joe is begging these monsters to spare
our embassy in kabul is this not
pathetic and naive and you got oh circle
back gensake encouraging the taliban to
consider their role they they're got to
consider their role in the international
community oh i'm sure this is their top
priority jen that's a genius comment
take a look
the taliban also has to make an
assessment about what they want their
role to be in the international
community and i know that ambassador
khalilzad made comments when he was at
the political negotiations yesterday
making clear that the international
community is going to watch closely how
the taliban behaves they have a range of
tools in their arsenal as well to take
steps should they choose
dear terrorists
what are you considering your role to be
in the international community
okay
let me paint the picture for you right
now jen as we speak according to the
reports taliban fighters are going door
to door and raping young girls as young
as 12 something they have done in the
past in case you don't know any history
they're executing anyone that stands in
their way one 22-year-old female
journalist is now being hunted for sport
by the taliban so jen
what do you think the taliban's role in
the international community should be
according to u.s officials its role will
soon be a top exporter of terrorism
worldwide once again and according to
marine general frank
mckenzie it's now only a matter of time
before al qaeda and isis assert
themselves and begin to plan their next
attacks against our homeland and now
thanks to biden's hasty retreat they
have plenty of american weapons at their
disposal joe he doesn't seem concerned
at all he had a hard time finding the
door to the white house and after a
two-week
two-day work week the president now has
departed the white house for another
vacation in delaware where we we are not
entitled to know what he does with a
major crisis at home and abroad the
leader of the free world missing in
action yet again